you also mentioned survival so that
seems to be a core principle that that
human existence is about survival can
you can you elaborate what is meant by
survival are we talking about the
survival of the human species survival
of the individual humans survival of the
manifestation of Satan's in human form
what what do we what's survival so it
would be all of that because survival is
the the dominant Force across all the
Dynamics
that I mean I'll run Hubbard it was
either Dianetics or science of survival
he
he says he discovered the principle
upon which all life exists and that is
all life no matter what it is trying to
do
are you ready Alex it's trying to
survive
that's pretty powerful that's pretty
powerful
no I I gotta tell you I gotta you might
get me back in no I'm not I'm not trying
to get you back in I'm trying to take
you uh get you to take seriously the
power of the ideas behind Scientology
because I think those ideas are not bad
ideas they resonate with a lot of ideas
throughout philosophy through our
religions throughout the history of
human civilization the interesting
aspect is how it goes wrong but here's
the thing like here's the thing it is
consistent with prior efforts or studies
it's just that L Ron Hubbard said this
was a watershed breakthrough that was
being discovered for the first time
that's kind of what I'm mocking really
yeah but you can mock Nietzsche for
saying man is Will To Power you can what
did he claim to be the first person to
ever say it well Nietzsche he's had a
bit of an ego so like and he's full of
contradictions but I'm pretty sure
the the imply thing is that he was the
first first to say it yeah there's a lot
of scientists there's a one of the
people I really admire is Stephen
Wolfram who uh wrote uh a book called A
New Kind of science that explores uh
complex systems and cellular automata
and these mathematical systems that have
been explored before but he boldly kind
of defined I am presenting to you a
whole new way to look at the world and
if you just set a little bit of the ego
behind that aside there's actually
beautiful ideas in there they have of
course been done before and explored
before but sometimes people declare the
coolest that's the only thing I'm really
mocking is yes this discovery that life
is trying to survive is greater than the
discovery of fire okay I mean it gets a
little silly but that's fine we can
agree that the fact that life is trying
to survive has meaning and is Meaningful
and can be is valuable and it's true I
mean life is trying to survive also
there's a non-trivial definition of what
is life here so this idea of a thing the
thing that permeates
through lifetimes yeah through people
there's some some fabric that is bigger
than the individual biological bags of
meat that's a philosophically
interesting idea of course if it's not
grounded in a little bit more uh a
physical reality then it becomes a
little to Google and the way I'll run
hybrid and Scientology defines survival
is very much intertwined with how they
Define ethics ethics anything you know
to be ethical is pro survival
to be unethical is counter survival but
we were talking about just the concept
of the Dynamics like what does survival
refer to and it actually does refer to
all of them but just keep in mind when
it comes to the seventh Dynamic thetans
collectively
um involved in here's the idea that a
thing cannot die there's no such thing
as killing a thing a thing can only can
only survive
and so um anyway uh this concept of the
Dynamics is one of the most fundamental
and important Concepts in Scientology
but but because I mentioned that it also
gets tied up with ethics and this
probably speaks to what you're just
talking about is you can have the ideas
and the concepts and you can have how do
they go wrong
because they hold
that Scientology applying Scientology
getting people into Scientology is the
key to basically saving every spiritual
being in existence
when you're analyzing what is ethical it
becomes whatever is good for Scientology
becomes by definition ethical because
anything that's good for Scientology
which is a third Dynamic is inherently
good for all the Dynamics so that's
where you get
the ends justifying the means to do any
anything possible and use any means
necessary to afford the aims of
Scientology that's kind of where a lot
of uh Soviet implementation of Communism
went wrong is the ends justify the means
the equality the justice for the workers
uh if we have to kill murder in prison
censor yeah in in the name of that then
it's it's for the greater good in the
long term to achieve the the ideal of
Communism in some respects Scientology
created a near perfect communist
experiment in its C organization
what is it from everyone according to
their ability to reach according to
their need or something like that
Scientology C organization is damn near
a perfect communist experiment
coming from someone who doesn't
necessarily know the perfect communist
experiment really is because I'm not
grew up in a cult Lex you can't use it
as an excuse It's a funny tagline of
using my videos I like it but like it is
interesting that an organization that is
so hyper capitalist and so money hungry
and is known to be very wealthy at its
core is run by these group of seog
members that live a communist lifestyle